joining us now from the white house is
john kirby the national security
council's coordinator for strategic
communications admiral it's good to see
you again good morning thanks very much
good to be with you
so let me ask you uh china is already
retaliating against speaker pelosi's
visit they're going to have military
drills they've got warplanes circling
taiwan
what is your plan for de-escalation and
should we be concerned
well i would say a couple of things one
this is exactly what we expected the
chinese to do we talked about this a
couple of days ago we expected them to
conduct some exercises and and to make
some more bellicose rhetoric out there
to fly uh aircraft of course uh in and
around uh the taiwan straits so
all of this is of a piece of what we
expected the chinese to do in terms of
reaction in terms of what goes on in the
in the future here we would again urge
the chinese not to escalate tensions any
more than they already are because
there's no reason to the trip is
complete it was completely consistent
with our obligations under the taiwan
relations act and with our one china
policy so we urge the the chinese uh to
look for opportunities to de-escalate
the tensions um and and to keep the
lines of communication open
so what is the message that speaker
pelosi is trying to send by visiting
taiwan what is the message the united
states is trying to send to china
well i won't speak for speaker pelosi
that's a co-equal branch of government
there she's the speaker of the house of
representatives i would just say that it
is important that the united states
be seen to and actually is
compliant with our policy and consistent
in that policy and we have long said no
change to the one china policy and we
long said that we don't support taiwan
independence and that we're going to
continue to support
taiwan's self-defense before you go wnba
star brittany greiner as you know could
be sentenced this week in russia any
progress on that prisoner exchange for
brittany griner and paul whalen
she's still wrongfully detained as is
paul whalen she shouldn't have to be
sitting and going through at trial we're
going to stay focused on making sure we
can get her home we're working on this
literally every day i don't want to go
into the details of the proposal but we
did make a serious proposal to the
russians they have not accepted that we
urge them to accept that because it is
serious and it will help bring paul
and brittany home back to their families
where they belong but i can assure you
that president biden and his entire team
is focused on that every single day
so so admiral have they responded at all
or is the ball still in their court
there is uh there are discussions going
on between both sides
we've made a serious proposal we urge
the russians to act on that proposal
admiral john kirby thank you very much
for appearing with us we appreciate it
my pleasure thanks vlad